the defeat did not come as a surprise
but still it was a major blow for
president alberto fernandez and his
ruling coalition party
six major districts out of eight voted
against the government resulting in the
peyronie's party losing its majority in
the senate for the first time in almost
40 years
supporters gathered to show their
support for the president
[Music]
they said the government needs to work
harder to convince those who didn't vote
for them
we need to call for consensus but it's
difficult because there are two extremes
the pandemic affected us all all of
government suffered this doesn't mean
that we need to correct mistakes and i
believe all of us are trying to make the
world a better place
argentina has been struggling to recover
from the pandemic
more than a hundred thousand people have
lost their lives but it's the impact on
the economy that drove the vote against
the ruling party the economic situation
is a main concern for people in
argentina inflation is close to 50
foreign reserves are low and the
government is negotiating a 40 billion
loan for the international monetary fund
the election results show that people
here are desperate for economic
stability
[Applause]
and it's disagreement over what to do
with the debt that has divided president
alberto fernandez and his powerful vice
president christina fernandez kushner
while he has prioritized ongoing
negotiations with the imf and has tried
to control the deficit kirschner has
pushed him to increase government
spending
in an attempt to control the damage and
mitigate the impact on the economy
fernandez announced that he'll present a
plan to congress in december to
negotiate with the imf
the plan has the support of his vice
president
to those who say that that problem with
the imf can be solved in five minutes i
can tell you that to negotiate is not to
obey i am sure that with austerity
measures we cannot even get the public
accounts in order
the election results strengthened the
conservative opposition party of former
president mauricio macri who left office
almost two years ago
the mayor of buenos aires oracio
rodriguez
said the election is crucial to take
power away from the ruling party
we had a historical election in the
province of buenos aires we beat them
again thanks to the people who want
change we know you are suffering with
insecurity with no jobs thanks for your
support but also thank you to those who
supported us across the country to get
those five senators to take absolute
power away from christina kirschner
argentina is divided between two
coalitions that cannot agree on how to
move the country forward
uncertainty is having an impact on
millions of people who are struggling to
make ends meet
analysts say only consensus can help the
country leave its ongoing economic
troubles behind teresa al jazeera buenos
aires